[Aplausos]
[Música]
afganistán es un país difícil en todos
sus aspectos y si decir esto es quedarse
muy cortos fijaos afganistán es un país
muy montañoso casi las tres cuartas
partes de su territorio están cubiertas
por montañas y picos que ojo en muchos
casos sobrepasan los 6000 metros de
altura ya os podéis imaginar lo difícil
que resultan aquí las comunicaciones
entre las diferentes regiones del país
por si fuese poco no tiene salida al mar
y la mayor parte del terreno es árido
los desiertos no son aquí un ecosistema
precisamente extraño
[Música]
vamos que exceptuando algún que otro
valle como el de herat lo que aquí
abundan de verdad en el paisaje nacional
son los tonos rojos ocres y amarillos
pero lo peor de afganistán no es ni su
orografía ni las duras condiciones
climáticas para nada lo peor de este
país es la pobreza la corrupción y sobre
todo el fundamentalismo y la violencia
porque amigos afganistán es sobre todo
un país en guerra fijaos en 1978 se
produjo la revolución de saúl una
revolución de corte comunista
un año más tarde en 1979 el ejército
rojo de la unión soviética invadió el
país para consolidar al gobierno
comunista pues bien desde entonces los
afganos no conocen la paz
[Música]
ojo tampoco es que antes estuvieran muy
bien
afganistán era es y probablemente será
por mucho tiempo uno de los países más
pobres del mundo y con unas condiciones
de vida más duras y hostiles
especialmente lo sabéis todos para las
mujeres
[Música]
en este país seis de cada diez personas
no saben leer ni escribir prácticamente
la mitad de la población no tiene acceso
a agua potable y es raro encontrar una
familia que no haya sido azotada por la
guerra y la violencia creo amigos que
podemos decir que afganistán es uno de
esos países donde es mejor no nacer pues
bien el último gran conflicto que aún
hoy perdura estalló en octubre de 2001
cuando el presidente de eeuu george bush
decidió invadir afganistán como
respuesta al 11-s por aquel entonces el
país estaba dirigido por los talibanes
un grupo religioso político
tremendamente radical que daba cobijo a
los miembros de al qaeda entre ellos al
mismísimo bin laden
beijing en el kingston la invasión fue
relativamente rápida los talibanes no
eran obstáculo para la impresionante
maquinaria de guerra norteamericana
ahora bien desde entonces han pasado 16
años y tres presidentes en la
que algunos llaman ya la guerra más
larga de la historia de eeuu ni siquiera
en la guerra de vietnam eeuu pasó tanto
tiempo y es que aunque parezca mentira
eeuu no está ganando
[Música]
qué está pasando
16 largos años de conflicto y ocupación
y cientos de miles de millones de
dólares después parecería lógico pensar
que eeuu y la otan
tendrían controlada la situación y que
afganistán estaría en vías de alcanzar
la paz nos parece pues nada de eso lo
cierto es que cada día que pasa los
talibanes recuperan terreno fijaos en
este mapa del 'washington post' las
zonas coloreadas son las zonas de
control que tienen los talibanes y ojo
porque este mapa refleja cuál era la
situación a principios de 2017 hoy las
cosas serían aún peores porque como
hemos dicho los talibanes están
recuperando terreno casi cada día las
últimas estimaciones amigos hablan de
que el gobierno de kabul estados unidos
y la otan controlan ya menos del 60 por
ciento del territorio si el próximo mapa
será todavía más rojizo
el gobierno afgano controla sólo el 57
por ciento del territorio pero la
pérdida de control del gobierno afgano y
por tanto de eeuu no sólo se observa
mirando el territorio también
la economía por ejemplo podemos
preguntarnos cómo se financian los
talibanes de dónde obtienen todos los
recursos que necesitan para dar la
batalla pues fundamentalmente de la
producción de heroína si tal cual como
lo escucháis afganistán es el mayor
productor mundial de opio que es el
ingrediente básico de la heroína ojo
porque no es solo que afganistán sea el
mayor productor mundial es que controla
entre el 80 y el 90 por ciento de toda
la producción mundial de opio y por
cierto sabéis de donde se extrae el opio
pues de la adormidera una planta que hoy
como podéis imaginaros es el cultivo
número uno de los agricultores afganos y
si en este país la mayor parte de la
población vive en el campo podemos decir
que la inmensa mayor parte de la
economía afgana depende de dos sectores
de los soldados internacionales y del
opio de hecho hay poco más pues bien
desde hace tiempo los talibanes
controlan la producción de opio en este
país pero ahora además se han dado
cuenta de que también pueden producir
ellos mismos
que es mucho más lucrativa el opio
recolectado se transforma aquí los
talibanes reciben mucho más dinero si
transforman el opio antes de que salga
del país y eso es lo que están haciendo
y es que las estimaciones hablan de que
los talibanes podrían recaudar con todo
esto unos 3 mil millones de dólares cada
año y eso a pesar de que eeuu se ha
gastado un montón de dinero en tratar de
combatir estas operaciones un esfuerzo
que como podéis ver en este gráfico no
ha servido para nada
y gracias a todos estos recursos los
talibanes están logrando mantener una
guerra que no solo les está permitiendo
ganar territorio sino que también ha
sumido al país en la violencia y lo peor
de todo es que los pronósticos no son
nada buenos los talibanes son cada vez
más fuertes el gobierno está en retirada
están perdiendo terreno para los
talibanes día a día
un dato el ejército talibán ha pasado de
estar formado por entre 2.000 y 10.000
soldados en el año 2005 a más de 60.000
hoy en día pero llegados a este punto
hay una pregunta obligatoria porque
estados unidos está perdiendo o al menos
porque no está ganando
la trampa afgana
en afganistán eeuu ha probado muchas
estrategias diferentes pero parece que
nada funciona de hecho en general existe
bastante pesimismo sobre este conflicto
casi nadie habla ya de ganar sino de
perder o no perder y no es una cuestión
sólo de más o menos soldados
cuando barack obama era candidato
repitió hasta la saciedad que afganistán
era una guerra que había que ganar
cuando llegó a la casa blanca puso sobre
el terreno a cien mil soldados
estadounidenses y otros cuarenta mil de
la otan pues ni aún así es verdad que
muchos dicen que el problema es que
obama en todo momento insistió en un
calendario de salida era algo así como
decirle a los talibanes oye que todo
esto es temporal pero lo cierto es que
más allá de ello los soldados de la
coalición internacional ocupaban las
zonas pero no conseguían influir en el
terreno porque primero porque hablamos
de un país tribal con una cultura de la
violencia muy consolidada no es fácil
para las tropas internacionales ganarse
la confianza de la gente distinguir
entre civiles y guerrilleros o saber
siquiera qué está pasando en el terreno
el salto cultural es enorme y además
tantos años de violencia actúan como una
especie de protección para los talibanes
ya están habituados a la intensidad y al
horror de la guerra por otro lado está
la corrupción y el descrédito del
gobierno veréis el gobierno afgano
carece prácticamente de instituciones
que puedan aportarle nada a los afganos
y encima las pocas que existen son
y corruptas de hecho este es uno de los
países más corruptos de todo el mundo a
los afganos corrientes no les gustan los
talibanes pero el gobierno afgano les
gusta aún menos la gente no muere por un
ejército muere por su país y quien
quiere morir por el gobierno afgano
actual entre esto y el miedo a los
talibanes es fácil entender por qué cada
mes ojo cada mes de ser tan casi 4.000
soldados y policías de las fuerzas de
seguridad del gobierno de kabul luego
hay que decir que la parte de la
estrategia de eeuu que tiene que ver con
el gobierno afgano con la política con
las instituciones no ha funcionado
washington ni siquiera ha conseguido que
el ejército afgano funcione
exceptuando unas fuerzas de operaciones
especiales de unos 17.000 hombres que
son los que prácticamente están
combatiendo en solitario a los talibanes
sí así es
obama entendió que la guerra en
afganistán tenían que llevarla a cabo
los propios afganos aunque eeuu pagará
las facturas y les diese cobertura aérea
nunca
efe berlín entre los problemas que está
también pakistán al que se acusa de dar
apoyo a los propios talibanes una
economía que no carbura y un montón de
intereses encubiertos por ejemplo si os
ha ocurrido qué interés tiene en pekín
teherán o moscú en que esta guerra
termine
tened clara una cosa estos países no
quieren que afganistán sea una especie
de colonia norteamericana por todo ello
tras casi 16 años de guerra la lucha
continua pero ahora en la casa blanca
hay un nuevo presidente
donald trump
[Música]
donde dije digo digo diego trump amigos
lleva años diciendo por activa y por
pasiva que la guerra de afganistán es un
monumental error que eeuu tiene que
largarse de allí lo dijo en su canal de
comunicación favorito twitter muchas
veces lo repitió una y otra vez en 2011
en 2012 en 2013 así hasta la campaña del
2016 cuando pararemos de gastar nuestro
dinero en reconstruir afganistán tenemos
que reconstruir nuestro país primero es
hora de salir de afganistán estamos
construyendo carreteras y escuelas para
gente que nos odia no están nuestros
intereses nacionales no permitáis a
nuestros muy estúpidos líderes firmar un
acuerdo que nos mantiene en afganistán
hasta 2024 con todos los costes a cargo
de eeuu hagamos a américa grande por
supuesto no pasó por alto la oportunidad
de meterse con obama
ahora obama va a dejar a nuestros
soldados en afganistán por al menos un
año más está perdiendo dos guerras al
mismo tiempo y ojo no era solo twitter
trump cada vez que podía insistir una y
otra vez afganistán era un error
mira mira lo que haré es el sector en
que twitter está what we don't care
árabe carsten weinstein miriam center
jane seriales en world girls y times and
health and sons of lights y claro en la
campaña electoral prometió como no que
eeuu se largaría de este país pero ahora
que es presidente bueno parece que las
cosas han cambiado
[Música]
la nueva postura de frank el pasado
lunes 21 de agosto desde una base
militar de virginia y en horario de
máxima audiencia
trump explicó su nueva estrategia y
bueno digamos que todo lo que había
dicho durante años quedó en nada la
nueva estrategia de trump amigos de
visual politics se parece tanto a la de
obama que cuesta distinguir las trampa
anunció más tropas pero tampoco muchas
más
básicamente el contingente pasará de
unos 12.000 soldados actualmente a unos
16.000 se dará prioridad al
entrenamiento del ejército afgano y a la
lucha contra el terrorismo se pondrá más
dinero se combatirá a la corrupción se
perseguirá a los malos
y se presionará más a pakistán vamos en
otras palabras más de lo mismo nada que
eeuu no haya hecho hasta ahora en lo que
si hay diferencia respecto a obama es en
dos cosas una que no habrá plazo de
retirada y dos que trump parece que pasa
de todo eso de construir instituciones
afganas de hecho con los recortes que va
a hacer en el departamento de estado
apuesta claramente por las armas
respecto a la política y la verdad no
está claro como trump espera conseguir
con unos 16.000 hombres lo que obama no
pudo con 140 mil o cómo piensa
estabilizar un país sin instituciones
que se ganan a la gente o que permitan
cierto desarrollo económico fijaos la
media de edad en este país es de poco
más de 18 años es decir la población es
muy muy joven jóvenes que hoy por hoy no
tienen trabajo ni futuro más allá de los
talibanes si kabul y washington no son
capaces de construir un marco de
oportunidades para todos ellos el fin de
la violencia estará muy lejos pero claro
esas cosas atrás
en fin 16 años después y tras decenas de
miles de bajas entre militares y civiles
y más de 800.000 millones gastados eeuu
continúa empantanada lo que muchos
llaman ya la trampa de afganistán y la
verdad
trump no parece proponer nada diferente
sin instituciones y sin
apuesta multilateral que tenga en cuenta
a los propios vecinos de afganistán como
china parece muy difícil que las armas
sean suficientes lo que sí parece claro
es que realmente trump es el populista
que parecía ser durante la campaña en
fin
turno para ti que crees que debe hacer
eeuu en afganistán
déjanos tu opinión en los comentarios y
también en esta encuesta si te ha
gustado el vídeo dale a like y no
olvides suscribirte a visual política un
saludo y hasta la próxima
life in my life
[Música]